on may first 2012 from courage attended
a press roundtable interview with raini
rodriguez from the film girl in progress
directed by patricia reagan this audio
is from that interview session for more
information on girl in progress please
visit girl in progress movie.com thank
you thank you we're just it sounds good
thing Oh trust me I was such a little
girl well I'm 18 I know what most people
think that I'm 12 so I can get away with
acting like a little kid no another bus
honest when you're 18 acting like a
little kid so like wow we want with you
but when you're when we look like you're
12 acting like you're 12 no questions it
looks perfect now you are the one girl
in the movie that is not really in
progress you pretty much done most of
yours [ __ ] together um I would say yeah
I mean it looked that way in the
beginning but i I've always sought as
you know that meet that was the one that
kind of went through the whole becoming
an adult and the rite of passage and she
kind of was the one that did all that in
the background while Sierra's character
on see God was trying to find herself
and trying to do it herself and I was
doing it in the background I think you
know so in a way I did kind of get into
the whole becoming an adult and going
through all the dramas and all the
hardships and then in the end you know
kind of it not working out within an end
up working out in the end I kind of
discovered myself and came out of it
successfully mm-hmm could you relate to
somebody in real life that you're
rolling we're um well I think everybody
in a way kind of does that I know like
even I growing up I would I would go
through different stages like nope i
only want to wear shorts I'm a shorts
kind of person I've decided and then you
know months later I'm like okay no jeans
I'm sorry I what was I thinking look at
the pictures gross no so it's kind of
like I think everybody goes through that
but I asked like a specific person that
I've seen Debbie dunno no they choose a
pretty unique kind of person why would
you
I've been so good though and when when
she cheated was going to just he was
just nice between say something to ask
to do you mentioned weekend but I mean I
like that you reacted so good to your
reaction to her thank you because what
did you think of someone that's never
been done to you have it no you know
I've never really experienced that type
of bullying and in public really like
yeah I mean I you hear people say
something about you but it's not it
doesn't hurt as much because it's not
necessarily to you so you don't know if
it's true or not but with that happening
especially with like somebody affects
her best friend aight i was crying i was
crying I've made Sierra cry multiple
times and rehearsals we had to stop
because she would just start apologizing
like immediately and I was like it's not
to me you're not hurting my feelings
you're hurting Thabeet that's to be a
thing that looks like it's totally
different I mean it's definitely
especially with bullying nowadays such a
hot topic it's a it's really important
to show that and to kind of showcase
that it really does happen it's not just
what you hear it actually does happen
and I mean plane is cleared happened to
delete that you know she kind of handled
it in a way that sort of the wrong way
she kind of just sort of shut down and
just went down the wrong path versus
maybe I'm talking to her make sure we
don't want to do it in the beginning
like go for the plan in the beginning
anyway and then it kind of backfired on
her and I don't know it was please dad
so now you really you really came forth
on the most of the world with Paul more
yes am I mean you don't never last donut
father Meehan's it's fitting that we see
ya you know you really came to the
forefront that was really your first big
motion picture major now here you are
again they're jumping between Disney TV
mm-hmm and film what do you find to be
the biggest difference and especially
given Disney shows in comparison to a
movie white girl in progress you know um
I book girl in progress and austin and
ally at the same time we were just
filming the pilot austin and Ally
act on Wednesday by friday i was in
canada filming go in progress so it kind
of happened pretty quickly as far as
adjusting I mean it was 100% different
you know girl in progress was this drama
and I've never really done drama before
I never had to cry on screen or scream
at my friends I never got to do any of
that in that was a big reason why I
wanted to do it because it just
showcased something completely different
you know it really kind of helped me
with my range of acting and to you know
prove to myself that I could do it not
just comedy and you know it's awesome
because uh the Disney Channel kids
they're so behind it they love it
they've seen the trailers and they're so
excited to see it not only because I'm
in it but just because of the story and
my cast is so supportive and just being
there was completely different because
you know you have to go from this goofy
character on this Disney show and then
turn it around and become you know this
young naive girl who then all of a
sudden goes through this huge
transformation in life and then kind of
falls from it and then has to rise back
up and it was interesting it was very
interesting from rehearsals to filming
you know it's everything's different you
know it takes five days to film an
episode of our show it took us two three
months to film a movie so it's complete
different working on the same thing over
and over again and you really get to
perfect it you really get to get to that
moment where it's perfect and you know
it cannot get any better than what
you're doing now versus a TV show which
is a little bit faster and you know more
fast paced and of course Disney you know
it's upbeat and light in so to go from
that to this is completely different but
i loved it i would love the opportunity
to do it again yes we've done TV you've
done film yes and you have any expected
any stage i would love to do stage i
would love to do theater i think that is
such an awesome experience this kind of
pair of contraction yeah it is it's also
different and it keeps you on your toes
and it keeps you fresh with an actor and
i love it when you're a young actress in
Hollywood and especially I'm not working
with Disney there comes a certain
expectation that you're going to be
someone aroma girls you know you're
younger how do you deal with that
expectation that
comes with that job I'm just myself I'm
not really a person that goes out and
likes to hang out a lot outside of my
house I'm very I'm very much a homebody
and I'm always with my family all the
time so I've doesn't I don't have to
worry about you know that kind of thing
and if kids want to look up to me that's
perfectly fine I will I'm always going
to set a good example because I have
nieces at home and I know that you know
if they ever saw me act out or act up i
would be embarrassed for them and to see
me that way so I would always try my
best of feel my best behavior did your
role models kind of work out for you did
they say like who you needed them to be
here to change most of them stay the
same yeah I mean you know I kind of I
get inspiration from everything and
everybody so it's kind of like you know
even if it's a fake character in a movie
or a TV show I kind of just get like
inspiration from everything so I don't
really have like these type of role
models that I would always look up to
but it's like there's a couple that come
to mind that i can think of i love them
when i was younger and i still love them
now and that's the way it always being
in the film you're given many chances to
assert your self-esteem the universe is
testing you and in many different areas
what would you recommend for other women
your age on how to feel good about
themselves there's so much pressure so
she was social media yeah and now this
new term Facebook depression where
everyone's comparing themselves to one
another how would you recommend that
young women should just feel good about
themselves no matter what the outside
sources throw at them I mean it really
just comes down to who you are I really
believe that I really believe that if
you just if you honestly love yourself
and even if you don't find something
that either fixes that may be like get
into a new hobby you know try singing
dancing juggling you know something to
help you you know you have to have a
good family base a good support system
not only family but friends you know if
it's the people that you're around that
are making you feel like you're not who
you are or less than them find new
people hang out with don't try to change
yourself to fit in with somebody else
you know find new people hang out with
that will accept you for you I'm just a
firm believer in being yourself no
matter who you are well when you uh you
say could you just
maybe two seas in this hemisphere where
you really had to check those
challenging yeah that's really thinking
over before you did up oh you mean look
as an actor I just mom well I'm
definitely to say in the cafeteria just
getting bullied on just because that
personally never had happened to me
before like in in person like I was
saying it and to kind of be in the
situation where I'm vulnerable and I
really can't do anything because you
know you have it worked out and then it
just kind of goes haywire you don't know
how to react and you know she's so naive
that she would never speak up to herself
anyway and and did it kind of happen I
really had to step back and think really
had to like put myself in a situation
and then immediately I just started
crying just thinking about it now I
could start crying just because of how
terrible it can be to really that can
happen in real life and that it does and
then definitely just like I don't know I
think like um better I think the ending
scene where we kind of make up as
friends yeah um as an actor I had to
really think about how my character
would feel I mean she went through this
whole emotional thing with her so-called
best friend and then you're supposed to
like become friends again and in my head
I was like I mean would she really
become best friends with her again and I
was like yeah she would because in a way
she helped her grow as a person maybe
not in a good way but she helped her you
know come out of her shell a bit more
but you know in the end friendship is
their bond was tight and it kind of was
was nice to see them you know reconcile
and become friends again and that was
another thing that I really wanted to
think about it you know I would talk to
Patricia about it all the time and ask
me know what do you think she were doing
this seen her you know i'ma think about
doing this and she's like you know what
that's perfect that's natural that's
exactly the way that she would act so no
Brady you've worked television is giving
you a chance to work with a lot of
different directors yes bouncing in and
out of the difference yeah reason all
now for your second feature you get a
female director mm-hmm female oriented
film how would you describe Patricia as
a director in comparison
what you're used to I loved her I mean
um I love that there are female
directors out there because i myself
won't become a director one day so to
kind of see her out there was amazing
and making a film you know about women
it was nice because she's actually a
woman and she can connect with you in
that way and you know even at rehearsals
and reading the script and going over it
I mean it was nice to see that she knew
what she was talking about you know
versus like coming from like a guy's
point of view or they don't know exactly
how that is but a woman is exactly what
you're talking about it was nice
Patricia was really was was wonderful I
mean we'd be in rehearsals and she would
it would just be this like empty room
just like us in a chair basically our
scripts and she would just talk with us
and say well you know how do you feel
with this and what do you feel like with
this and do you like this line is it
natural we could change it you know it's
just kind of however you felt she was
really good about working with you and
letting you do your own thing and I love
that ring oh sorry go ahead the thing
yes so um just really quickly the
controversy recently about the film
called bully mm-hmm and you know that's
such like you said a hot topic and there
were like decisions about the rating and
all that and what do you anticipate you
think this is like similar type of like
what kind of feedback and what kind of
response you think box-office wise um
i'm chubbing for the best I really am I
mean that's really all you can as an
actor is just you put your all into a
project and you just hope for the best
that's really all you can hope for it
does you know brush up on the topic of
bullying obviously its showcase but I
mean it's not necessarily something
that's the main corner of the film it
just kind of showed that under pressure
she had to bully her best friend that
wasn't the right choice to make because
that sort of wasn't how it was supposed
to go exactly um you know it could have
happened differently she could have just
not done this whole thing and just
stayed herself and that would have been
fine but I mean it obviously happened so
it's good that it's shown
it shows you know the side effects of
what happens when you are bullied and
you know the the troubles that you can
go through like to me that did because
of the fact that her best friend bullied
her now she doesn't have anybody else to
turn to but the wrong crowd yes sir you
mentioned that you're 18 gonna be 19 in
July yes but you're gonna get to vote
for the first time ever being very
excited but the impression that we here
and get following the news is that kids
today are very disillusioned with
politics and is it still exciting the
prospecting for the first time you're
going to be able to get involved in
politics um it is interesting it's nice
to know that you count you have a voice
you're able to make a difference because
you don't know if my book could go this
way or that way you really don't know
it's nice to kind of you know say you're
a team you have sort of this you know
another responsibility its eyes I'm
excited for it I can't wait yes this is
a film full of some Latino palutena
powerhouse walls so what's your feeling
about that I mean when you're saying
these women just running the show I love
it I love it I love it I absolutely love
it you know I've uh I'm so happy to be
part of a Latina based film product
whatever you want to call it I'm happy
to be a part of it I'm happy to say that
I'm a part of this wonderful movie you
know to work with Patricia and Ava and
Sierra I mean it's great it's great to
know the role at the enough because it's
definitely out there you know there's a
lot of single moms that are latina with
you know kids and stuff like that and
you know best friends and everything
that it's shown it it so it's very real
it's very real so it's nice to be part
of it you were in your earlier the you
said you were questioning whether she
could actually forgive her husband or
not were you questioning that because
you don't think you would be as
forgiving in that situation um I I don't
think personally myself I could ever be
as forgiving because it was a lot that
she went through I made a lot a lot so I
don't know if I could ever forgive her
as much as what the visa did but i think
i could eventually but it would take a
lot more time than what it took for
bebida de mita was i mean because that
was really much pretty much her only
best friend ever and then
kind of figure out that it really wasn't
intentional that she really didn't mean
to do that like all me in when it all
came and said and done and you know I
think it it's a lot when you kind of hit
rock-bottom like that we done it and
then you kind of realized oh I kind of
do need her my bad and then it kind of
works out because you know on see God
realized that to about that be done it
signs I don't know if I could be quite
as forgiving just cuz she heard through
a lot I mean from her being her best
friend I wouldn't want to enemy like
that girl did she at any time ever
consider her wealth as something that
she could manipulate with Vanita yeah um
no in a way I felt maybe anyway I just
feel like it was it was able to help her
get friends in her mind you know she did
not address but she would see this style
this on this all think oh I have money
I'll buy all those styles and put them
together here just like know that is
more that way any of helping on to God
with her plan you know what we would
always talk about wall until that need
money you know to get this and to figure
out this and to create that beautiful
billboard that's in her room she needs
money for that so obviously thumb betta
was more than welcome to help her with
anything so I flick in a way it kind of
the money kind of backfired for her
because it didn't really help with
anything it just it just kind of made
her used people use her a lot bored I
think